يا شعبنا العظيم يا صانع
المعجزات يا امتنا ويا احرار
العالم ان جل ما قاومنا ونقاوم به عدوان
الصهاينه هو من صنع كتائب القسام من عبوات
ناسفه ومقذوفات صاروخيه وراجمات
ومدافع ومضادات للدروع وقنابل مختلف
انواعها وبنادق القنص وحتى
الرصاص وهذه الصناعات
لم تكن لتجدي نفعا امام الترسانه
الامريكيه الهائله
القذره التي نواجهها في ايدي مرتزقه
الصهاينه في الميدان لولا الصناعه الاهم
التي نمتلكها وهي صناعه الانسان
المقاتل ذلك الفلسطيني المقاوم
المجاهد الذي لا تقف قوه في الارض امام
ارادته واصراره على مواجهه قاتلي اجداده
وابائهم
ومدني مسراه ومحتل تراب وطنه كما ان اساءه
وجه هذا العدو وكسر عدوانه لم تكن لتحدث
لولا عطاء وصمود وعظمه شعب حر كريم شامخ
يجود بكل عزه وكبرياء بكل شيء ولا يعطي
الدنيه في وطنه وارضه
ومقدساته فماذا ستفعل تكنولوجيا الصواريخ
والدبابات المحصنه والطائرات الحديث
باسلحتهم الفتاكه امام قوه ايمان مجاهد
يمكث شهرين واكثر في عقدته الدفاعيه
وموقعه
المتقدم منتظرا الظفر بعدوه وتنفيذ مهمته
محتسبا كل ذلك لله مؤمنا بعداله
قضيته وان شهادات مجاهدين الابطال
العائدين من خطوط المواجهه في شمال ووسط
وجنوب
القطاع يؤكد مدى بطولتهم العظيمه وايمانهم
الكبير
بمعركته واستبسال في الدفاع والهجوم
والتصدي وهم في المقابل يعودون بشهادات
صادمه عن ضعف ايمان ودافعيه الجندي
الصهيوني والمرتزقه اللمم وكيف يجرون الى
القتال
جرا وكيف يبكون فزعا وجزع ويفرون امام
مجاهدينا رغم كل ما يحملونه من سلاح وعتاد
وغطاء ناري ضخم وان ما يعرضه جيش العدو
وما يعلن عنه من بطولات موهومه
لجنوده هو محل سخريه لاصغر طفل فلسطيني